Chad here we are Chad Johnson made an  explosive appearance on The Bachelorette  men tell all Tuesday Jordans stuck out  his hand to you and said that was  straight bull I was at the taping and  chatted with the Chad how are you  feeling I feel pretty good you know I  got to say what I wanted to say so were  you walking away with some friends  tonight I don't know not why I came here  maybe I should have punched somebody  maybe if I punch one person they'd have  been like dude you said that maybe you  should have punched someone to shut  everybody up who would you have punched  you want to go for the big guy first  obviously Jordan yeah a good target okay  a lot of size closer together than they  already are  one regret that you have from the show  one we regret the only regret that I  have is thinking that threatening the  dudes would get them to shut up did not  work did not work other than no regrets  I mean I was myself I did my thing